let's talk about trollhunters many
things to observe I really like this
show it's really well animated yeah and
you're the voice of one of the troll
blinky blinky and it's a terrific show
you're the voice of your brother is this
Mark Hamill is Mark Hamill what's
interesting variable yeah and what's
interesting is that I didn't even
realize this but you as a very young man
auditioned for the part of Han Solo yes
in the first Star Wars movie I didn't
know this is a good yarn - okay this is
end up with you naked eating pasta it
well if it had I would have gotten the
part I had just been thrown out of
Juilliard no this is always go way back
to begin my stories don't yeah but uh
there was a woman there at the taught
school Edith Skinner was her name she
was the voice teacher and it had sort of
helped invent the phonetic alphabet she
pulled me aside and said Kelsey you know
these things happen you know some people
leave school they do very well and she
was right prophetically but she said you
have Caruso equipment I said oh that's
very nice and she said you speak
beautifully and I want to put you in
touch with an agent and I thought wow
that's great I was twenty years old and
so she introduced me to Mort Schwartz
was his name and when I walked into his
office he had a Dutch door there was a
secretary here and then there was a
Dutch door and you could see Mort you
know through the top door open right but
you couldn't get through the bottom door
right but I looked in and and he said
yeah what do you want what do you want
and he's on the phone with Gregory Peck
he says yeah Greg just give me a minute
so I thought well maybe he's maybe it's
easy leave it really yeah he's just like
peck on the phone yeah okay but then he
said what do you want I said well he did
Skinner sent me over he said hey wait a
minute
there's a guy two blocks up the street
but he's looking for it for young men
for this movie about outer space and he
said don't worry about her space his
name is yeah his name is Lucas and go go
see him and I said great great he's at
this address
I walked up there and I sat down and
there's there's a Lukas sitting there
and he explains to me that they're doing
this movie about a fairy tale in space
and said there's two guys in it who go
and rescue a princess oh that's pretty
much it and he said I think maybe you're
a little old for them for the younger
guy maybe a little too young for the
older guy but you know you might make a
pretty good sort of like a John Wayne
character and I said oh oh I can do that
and uh I mean he he said well I'll think
about it and then that's the last I
heard about two years later cut to two
years later I'm sitting in San Diego I
was working at the Shakespeare Festival
there and I sat down to this movie and
it's been an ad in the big the big
Cruiser goes across the sky and then
it's Star Wars and I suddenly realized
oh my god this is that movie that's that
weird guy but a guy Lucas the biggest
movie in the yeah so I'm really really
missed one there
[Applause]
you